Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师Lisa Johnson共同举办的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战赛。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up on today's episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, I talk to Dr.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的《准心理学家播客》中，我将与Marianne Trent博士
Marianne Trent about her journey from the NHS into her own private practice. We drop into Marianne starting third year of her doctorate and we go through the journey into qualification through some years working in the NHS service as a qualified and then blended and eventually full-time into private practice. Talk a little bit about standardised ways of working, the skills and knowledge and also how it feels and what kind of person maybe would succeed in private practice. We cover a little bit of the pros and cons including what both private and NHS can potentially uniquely offer for clients. And we also finish with some kind of big old reflections on the future.
探讨她从英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）转型到私人执业的历程。我们将从Marianne博士学位的第三年聊起，回顾她获得资格后的几年NHS工作经历，以及后来兼职、最终全职投入私人执业的过程。我们还会谈谈标准化的工作方式、所需的技能和知识，以及私人执业需要什么样的特质。我们讨论了私人执业和NHS各自的优缺点，以及它们能为客户提供的独特价值。最后，我们还对未来进行了一些深刻的思考。
Word of warning, this episode is a little bit longer than usual, clocking in about an hour and 20 minutes. But obviously you can duck in and out of that at your leisure. So thank you for listening. I hope you enjoy it and see you soon. You'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. Hello, and welcome to the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. But wait, I know what you're thinking. This isn't Dr. Marianne Trent. But wait, I know what you're thinking. This isn't Dr. Marianne Trent. Who is this guy? Why is he here? And what's going on? Dear listener, worry not. Allow me to explain. My name is Thomas Gawley. And aside from lots
温馨提示，本期节目比平时稍长，大约一小时二十分钟。当然，你可以根据自己的时间随时收听。感谢大家的收听，希望你们喜欢，我们很快再见。你将走上获得资格的道路。这里是《准心理学家播客》，我是Marianne Trent博士。你好，欢迎收听《准心理学家播客》，我是Marianne Trent博士。等等，我知道你在想什么。这不是Marianne Trent博士。等等，我知道你在想什么。这不是Marianne Trent博士。这家伙是谁？他为什么在这里？发生了什么事？亲爱的听众，别担心。让我来解释一下。我叫Thomas Gawley。除了生活中
of other things in my life, I'm also a trainee clinical psychologist. A few weeks ago, I was a guest on the podcast. and Marianne and I talked afterwards about topics for future episodes. I said I'd be really interested to hear an episode about working privately and Marianne's journey from the NHS into her own practice. Marianne agreed that this would make an interesting topic, but what might not be too interesting for listeners would be, in Marianne's own words, to listen to her waffle on to herself about her own career. Instead, she suggested that it would be far better to be interviewed herself. And so the pyramid has been inverted and the former podcast guest becomes the current podcast host. That's me. So that's what we're going to do today. And I'm going to ask Marianne lots of questions about her journey out of the DeClin into her
的许多其他事情外，我还是一名临床心理学实习生。几周前，我曾是该播客的嘉宾。之后，Marianne和我讨论了未来节目的主题。我说我对关于私人执业以及Marianne从NHS转型到私人执业的历程非常感兴趣。Marianne同意这是一个有趣的话题，但用她自己的话说，听她一个人喋喋不休地谈论自己的职业生涯，对听众来说可能没那么有趣。相反，她建议由别人来采访她会更好。于是，金字塔倒转了，前播客嘉宾变成了现任播客主持人。那就是我。所以这就是我们今天要做的。我将问Marianne很多关于她从临床心理学博士课程（DeClin）毕业后，
qualified career and then her journey into private practice. And we're going to make some kind of general comparisons and maybe a few specific comparisons about those two different career paths. But first, it's DeClin application season, of course, so we're all ready to go. One thing that we need to remind you of is that the Clearinghouse will contact your referees as soon as you save them on your application form. That means that they will be contacted before you even finish your application and submit it. So quick note, make sure that you get consent from your referees before you add them and save them on the form,
进入职业生涯，再到私人执业的问题。我们将对这两种职业道路进行一些一般性和具体的比较。但首先，现在是临床心理学博士课程（DeClin）的申请季，大家都准备好了。我们需要提醒大家的一点是，Clearinghouse（申请中心）会在你保存申请表后立即联系你的推荐人。这意味着他们在你完成并提交申请之前就会被联系。所以请注意，在将推荐人添加到表格并保存之前，请务必获得他们的同意，
because Clearinghouse will take that as consent and that they're OK to contact them. So consent first and they will get contacted before you've submitted your form. So without further ado, welcome to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, not with Dr. Marianne Trent, but me, Thomas Gawley. And today's guest is none other than Dr. Marianne Trent. Hello, Marianne. How are you? Hi, I loved that. That's so fun. Thank you. Very, very pleased to be here. And I feel like I'm in very capable hands, thanks. Good, so I'm going to drop straight into it and I'm going to take you back to the start of your third year is probably also the start of the end of the training, and therefore maybe a time where trainees naturally start to think about what's going to happen post-qualification
因为Clearinghouse会将其视为已获得同意，并认为可以联系他们。所以一定要先获得同意，因为他们在你提交表格之前就会被联系。废话不多说，欢迎收听《准心理学家播客》，今天的主持人不是Marianne Trent博士，而是我，Thomas Gawley。今天的嘉宾正是Marianne Trent博士。你好，Marianne。你好吗？嗨，我喜欢这个开场。太有趣了。谢谢。非常非常高兴能来到这里。而且我觉得自己被照顾得很好，谢谢。好的，那我们直接切入正题，把你带回博士三年级的开始，这可能也是培训结束的开始，因此也是实习生自然开始思考毕业后会发生什么的时候，
and what kind of routes they want to take, maybe what services, maybe they're thinking about what placements they might want to do in third year and how that might lead into post qualification or not um so I guess to start um take us back to the start of third year what what were you doing and what were you thinking about post quality okay great question so um in the course or on the course should I say that the that I did um the third year is broken up into two placements two specialist placements that you really start to to pave the way for probably in year one really um and my first specialist placement was um in a wonderful wonderful service that's since been
他们想走什么样的路线，可能在考虑想在三年级做哪些实习，以及这是否会导向毕业后的职业发展。所以我想先从三年级开始，你当时在做什么？你在考虑毕业后的打算吗？好的，很好的问题。在我参加的课程中，三年级被分为两个专业实习，你从一年级开始就真的在为这些实习铺路。我的第一个专业实习是在一个非常棒的服务机构，遗憾的是，该机构后来
disbanded actually unfortunately um but it was a systemic and family therapy service offering some solution focus, but also, yeah, like there was proper sort of family therapy rooms in there. I don't know if you or anyone else has seen them, but they've got one way mirrors and, you know, phones that you can talk through and things like that. So it was in there. But then I also did some had some clients for, yeah, brief solution focus, where you'd actually only offer appointments every four weeks, I think it was. So you're really setting kind of achievable, realistic targets and goals between sessions. But it was also a self referral services, like they were doing all of the really great stuff. And and also once a week on a Wednesday lunchtime they'd do a drop-in for any difficulties you were having um I think it wasn't just linked to children but often it would be children um or parents that were brought in I think it I can't quite remember I think it might have been a specific family support drop-in so literally you could come half an hour
解散了。那是一个系统式家庭治疗服务机构，提供一些以解决方案为导向的治疗，而且那里确实有正规的家庭治疗室。我不知道你或其他任何人是否见过，但那里有单向透视镜，还有可以通过电话进行沟通的设备等等。我在那里工作。我还接待了一些客户，进行简短的解决方案导向治疗，我想当时每四周才提供一次预约。所以你真的需要在会话之间设定可实现、现实的目标。那也是一个自助转诊服务，他们做了很多非常棒的事情。而且每周三午餐时间，他们还会为遇到困难的人提供免预约服务。我想这不仅仅针对儿童，但通常是儿童
before give your name to reception and then you know be seen for 20 minutes with a qualified psychologist to think through your difficulties and come up with a plan and then as a result of that the clinician who'd seen would then write an assessment report and send on any referrals that were needed so you didn't hold that as a caseload. And if they wanted to be seen again, they could. But actually, people didn't tend to. It was such a wonderful, wonderful way of working. And I learned so much.
或家长被带过来。我记不太清了，我想那可能是一个专门的家庭支持免预约服务，所以你真的可以在半小时前到达，向接待处报上名字，然后与一位合格的心理学家进行20分钟的交流，梳理你的困难并制定计划。结果，接待你的临床医生会写一份评估报告，并转介任何必要的服务，所以你不需要承担这些案例。如果他们想再次咨询，也可以。但实际上，人们通常不会。这是一种非常棒的工作方式。我学到了很多。
And, you know, not even knowing anything, other than someone's name before you see them, I really learned how to think on my feet and how to think about our core skills as psychologists and you know building rapport and trying to also probably interject when things are getting too content heavy to think actually we've only got 20 minutes if if by any chance they were the only people that turned up or there were other clinicians, there was always other clinicians. But if it was a quiet time, then potentially you could go up to
而且，在见到某人之前，除了知道他们的名字外，我对他们一无所知，我真的学会了如何随机应变，如何思考我们作为心理学家的核心技能，比如建立融洽关系，以及当内容过于沉重时，如何适时介入，思考“实际上我们只有20分钟”。如果碰巧只有他们来，或者有其他临床医生在场——总是有其他临床医生在场。但如果当时比较安静，那么你可能可以延长到
an hour. But really, the idea was that in that hour you were seeing three clients and it was wonderful. So that was my placement there. And that was supervised by a clinical psychologist. It was a very big team, actually. And I think even trainee-wise, there was a trainee room up in the attic, and it was, I think there was, at different times of the week, there was probably four or five of us. So it was very busy, but I learned a lot. And then placement six was a dynamic placement, psychodynamic,
一小时。但实际上，这个想法是在那一小时内接待三位客户，这太棒了。这就是我在那里的实习。由一位临床心理学家监督。那是一个非常大的团队。我想即使是实习生，阁楼上也有一个实习生室，我想在一周的不同时间，可能有四五个人。所以非常忙碌，但我学到了很多。然后第六个实习是一个动力学实习，心理动力学，
brief dynamic interventions, which was something I was very interested about in my first year um but actually as I develop my confidence um and just you just create new interests and new ways of being because I see placements as a way of trying on different stuff that fits and actually by the time placement six came I was much less interested in dynamic and probably you know I learned loads it was a great placement everyone was really lovely to me so I don't want to talk down that placement but certainly because of how long it takes to get into placement six my my interest for that were were less strong at
简短的动力学干预，这是我在一年级时非常感兴趣的东西。但实际上，随着我自信心的增强，你会产生新的兴趣和新的存在方式，因为我把实习看作是尝试不同适合自己的东西的过程。实际上，当第六个实习到来时，我对动力学的兴趣已经大大降低了。我学到了很多，那是一个很棒的实习，每个人对我都很友善，所以我不想贬低那个实习，但肯定是因为进入第六个实习需要很长时间，我对它的兴趣在
that time and I haven't worked dynamically since but I guess what I love about our work is that the theory is all up there still and sometimes with our integrative way of working sometimes it will just fit and I can kind of weave in some more um you know some more dynamic ways of working but of course alongside all of this um you have a personal life as well don't you and you've got cohort stuff and you've got a thesis so there was a study block in between placement five and six um where all sorts of things happen for context it's when um william and kate got married that's that sort of time it's that long ago um And that was the end of my that was the end of my study block, I seem to recall, because the rest of the world was watching the the wedding and I was beaver and happy I'd been living in my new house which is not this one for um for a year and I'd been with my boyfriend um who is now my
当时已经没那么强烈了，从那以后我也没有再做过动力学方面的工作。但我认为我热爱我们工作的一点是，理论仍然在那里，有时通过我们整合的工作方式，它会很契合，我可以融入一些更……你知道，更具动力学的工作方式。当然，在所有这些的同时，你也有个人生活，对吧？你有同学，还有论文。在第五和第六个实习之间有一个学习阶段，发生了各种各样的事情。作为背景，那是威廉和凯特结婚的时候，那是很久以前的事了。那是我的
husband we had met um in the first two weeks of um my year two study block I think so that's kind of yeah I started the course single and then went went on the coupledom journey from year two but um yeah there's a very long answer to your question does that kind of does that answer it does that illuminate some of what was going on for me um yeah yeah it gives us gives us a good idea of where you're at. I'm wondering, of course, both those placements, I'm assuming, were in the NHS, as they tend to be, although I'm aware that it is possible to arrange third year placements on some courses privately. So getting towards the end of your time on the doctorate, what were you thinking about qualification? Did you have a job secured before you'd finished?
学习阶段的结束，我记得，因为全世界都在看婚礼，而我正在忙碌。我很高兴我已经在我的新房子里住了一年，那不是现在这一间。我当时和我的男朋友在一起，他现在是我的
As I'm aware, most trainees I've met have that lined up. Was that in the NHS? And either way, what was it doing? Okay, so to set the context, we're talking about 2011 when I qualified. And due to some kind of financial shenanigans involving various banks and mortgage companies, including Northern Rock, which no longer exists, there was a recession, which was in full swing at that time. It didn't feel as bleak as the 2023 landscape, actually, because we hadn't also had a global pandemic. But at that time, actually, there seemed to be cuts across services, and there were very, very few jobs available. So of my cohort of what started as 15 but finished as 16 due to kind of maternity leave shifts from the year above um only i think two people had qualified jobs to go to when the course ended in september 2011 um it started to creep up um yeah yeah it started to creep up I guess that's unrecognizable that
丈夫。我们是在我二年级学习阶段的前两周认识的，我想。所以，是的，我开始课程时是单身，然后从二年级开始进入了情侣生活。但，是的，这是一个对你问题的很长的回答。这能回答吗？这能阐明当时我身上发生的一些事情吗？是的，这让我们对你的处境有了很好的了解。我想知道，当然，我假设这两个实习都是在NHS进行的，因为它们通常是这样，尽管我知道在某些课程中安排私人三年级实习是可能的。所以，在博士课程快结束时，你在考虑获得资格吗？你在完成之前就找到工作了吗？
situation to trainees now where you might be the only person interviewing for the job you might be the only person applying for the job um so yeah that's that's a big change um yeah and to be honest it was finding the jobs to apply to was the problem there just weren't any um you know quite often trainees might even get jobs in their final year you know sometimes services will wait you know almost a year for the right candidate but it was just like you know to begin with it was like hmm there's not really there's not really many jobs around is there um wonder where they're all hiding um oh I have got bills to pay like hmm um but actually as it went um what happened is that basically probably all of that cohort across
据我所知，我遇到的大多数实习生都已经安排好了。那是在NHS吗？无论如何，那是做什么的？好的，为了设定背景，我们谈论的是2011年我获得资格的时候。由于涉及包括Northern Rock（现已不存在）在内的各家银行和抵押贷款公司的金融闹剧，当时正处于经济衰退期。实际上，它感觉不像2023年的环境那么凄凉，因为我们当时还没有经历全球大流行。但在那时，各服务机构似乎都在削减开支，可用的工作岗位非常非常少。所以，我们那一届最初有15人，由于上一届的产假变动，最终有16人，我想只有两个人
the country began to widen their search so I ended up in a role that was further away than any of my placements had been even though the way placements are allocated you know I never got a placement that was like right near where I lived I think my shortest commute was 15 minutes so my longest during training was probably 50 minutes but my qualified commute ended up being over an hour um so all of us probably yeah as a as a as a just as a whole graduate cohort across the country probably widened our search for where we were willing to consider um and really because of the the flavor of the work i'd done i didn't really have any strong preference to a clinical population at that point um but i'd only worked the majority of my work, including training, had been with adults.
在2011年9月课程结束时有合格的工作岗位。它开始慢慢增加……是的，它开始慢慢增加。我想这对现在的实习生来说是无法想象的，你可能是一个职位的唯一面试者，你可能是一个职位的唯一申请者。所以，是的，这是一个巨大的变化。说实话，找到可以申请的工作才是问题所在，根本就没有。你知道，通常实习生甚至可能在最后一年就找到工作，有时服务机构会为了合适的候选人等待近一年。但当时的情况就像是，嗯，周围真的没有多少工作，不是吗？想知道它们都藏在哪里。哦，我还有账单要付，像……嗯。但实际上，随着时间的推移，
And so nobody was more surprised than me when I got a CAMHS job in basically the heart of Birmingham, but also Sutton Coalfield. And when I was told I was in Sutton Coalfield, I was like, I've heard of Sutton Caulfield, but I don't know where it is. So nobody was more surprised than that than me. But actually, I loved it and I made a great CAMHS clinician. And what I really, really loved about CAMHS was just how energetic and joy filled the team were and how passionate about young people and they were just really vibrant people which might sound really strange but um when I was an aspiring psychologist and certainly when I was training it used to be said that if you go to and this is a complete over generalization please don't be triggered by this anybody, but this is kind of some of the, just some of the in-house conversations. If you
全国那一届的毕业生开始扩大他们的搜索范围。所以我最终得到的工作地点比我任何一个实习地点都要远，尽管实习分配的方式，我从来没有得到过离我住的地方很近的实习。我想我最短的通勤时间是15分钟，所以我在培训期间最长的是50分钟，但我的合格通勤时间最终超过了一个小时。所以我们所有人可能都扩大了我们愿意考虑的范围。真的，因为我所做工作的风格，当时我对临床人群没有任何强烈的偏好。但我大部分的工作，包括培训，都是针对成年人的。
go to a substance abuse conference as a professional, the bar will be rammed, you know, and similarly, if you're working in an adult service, the clinicians might well have some of their own struggles whereas working in CAMHS everyone was just yeah at that point just vibrant and you know really positive and optimistic in a way that was so refreshing especially as that was my first qualified job and it felt it just felt really weird it felt really weird I think I've mentioned in the podcast before that I was expecting and sort of kind of hoping for kid gloves that I'd have like a a period of transitioning to this new qualified role but my manager who I am now good friends with um she was basically like we've been waiting for you
所以当我在伯明翰市中心，但也包括Sutton Coldfield得到一份CAMHS（儿童和青少年心理健康服务）工作时，没有人比我更惊讶了。当我被告知我在Sutton Coldfield时，我说，我听说过Sutton Coldfield，但我不知道它在哪里。所以没有人比我更惊讶了。但实际上，我爱上了它，我成为了一名出色的CAMHS临床医生。我真正热爱CAMHS的是团队的活力和充满快乐，他们对年轻人充满热情，他们是非常有活力的人。这听起来可能很奇怪，但当我是一名准心理学家，当然当我还在接受培训时，人们常说——这是一个完全的过度概括，请不要因此感到被冒犯——但这只是内部的一些对话。如果你
and you're qualified away you go and I think that was empowering so they were thinking of me as qualified I mean in terms of um I don't know if Kappa still exists but a choice and partnership approach that's how the service worked and it worked beautifully and it won awards for patient safety it was a great service um but in terms of how it works with kappa is that you don't suddenly get like 15 cases given to you it builds week by week so that did allow me to have more time to think to plan to you know make sure my notice board next to my desk looked nice all those things but it meant that I wasn't suddenly swamped with activities. So I did get to grow into that role. Whereas I think still some services might have been tempted to,
作为专业人士去参加药物滥用会议，酒吧会挤满人，你知道，同样，如果你在成人服务机构工作，临床医生可能自己也有一些挣扎。而在CAMHS工作，每个人都非常……是的，在那一点上只是充满活力，你知道，非常积极和乐观，这让人耳目一新，尤其是因为那是我的第一份合格工作，这感觉非常奇怪。我想我在播客中提到过，我期待并希望得到“温和对待”，我希望有一个过渡到这个新合格角色的时期。但我的经理，我现在和她是好朋友，她基本上说，我们一直在等你，
you know, you're new, have this, and then juggle your new client that comes in three weeks out of four. But that didn't happen. So I was thankful for that. But I was just a qualified member of staff and expected to to roll with it yeah I'm obviously being at the stage in my career I'm out I'm kind of focused on the transition uh onto the doctorate but yeah I'm also aware that there's there's been another another big transition and i know a former supervisor of mine uh talked about uh about that transition in supervision and and kind of
你已经合格了，去吧。我认为这赋予了我力量，所以他们把我视为合格的专业人士。我的意思是，关于……我不知道Kappa（选择与伙伴关系方法）是否仍然存在，那是该服务的工作方式，它运作得非常完美，并获得了患者安全奖，这是一个伟大的服务。但就Kappa的工作方式而言，你不会突然被分配15个案例，它是每周逐步增加的。这确实让我有更多时间去思考、计划、确保我办公桌旁边的公告栏看起来不错，所有这些事情。但这意味着我不会突然被活动淹没。所以我确实得以成长到那个角色中。而我认为有些服务机构可能很想，
described it as being you know where where before you're qualified you you don't have ultimate clinical responsibility because you have a supervisor who is responsible for you ultimately, you know. And he said, you know, in kind of getting registered after he'd qualified, he'd gone from Friday having no ultimate clinical responsibility to Monday, suddenly it's all on him. And, you know, he's got assistant as well. So, yeah, I can imagine that's a difficult transition to make. But you've made that transition and you've gone into your qualified role. So I'm wondering how long were you at that CAMHS service for? And I suppose, where did the journey into your own practice begin, both in your mind or your ambition? Was it something that you were planning to do or was it something that just kind of emerged?
你知道，你是新人，拿着这个，然后处理你每四周来三次的新客户。但这并没有发生。所以我很感激。但我只是一个合格的员工，并被期望去适应它。是的，我显然处于职业生涯的这个阶段，我专注于向博士课程的过渡。但我也意识到还有另一个巨大的过渡。我知道我的一位前主管在督导中谈到了那个过渡，并将其描述为：在你获得资格之前，你没有最终的临床责任，因为你有一位对你最终负责的主管。他说，在他获得资格并注册后，他从周五没有最终临床责任，到周一，突然一切都压在他身上。而且，他还有助手。所以，是的，我可以想象这是一个很难的过渡。但你已经完成了那个过渡，并进入了你的合格角色。所以我很好奇，你在那个CAMHS服务机构待了多久？我想，你进入私人执业的旅程是从哪里开始的，无论是在你的想法还是抱负中？这是你计划要做的事情，还是它只是自然而然地出现了？
Yeah, how did that come about? OK, so I was there almost four years, but that did include one little maternity leave and a wedding and all the hen shenanigans that went with that um so yeah I wasn't planning on doing private work so before I um before I got my qualified job, I did do some brief project work for organizations, which was basically sort of using my research skills and trying to kind of put together a report for an organization, which I did really enjoy. But to be honest, the idea for private work wasn't my own it was um it was offered to me as an idea by my husband um so um I'd had a second um lot of maternity leave when I was working in an adult service so I left that cam service to come to a an adult service it was closer to home um and again really really valued my time there and I learned so much and that's when I became a trauma specialist is what I would say um and I miss my
是的，那是怎么发生的？好的，我在那里待了近四年，但这确实包括一次小产假、一场婚礼以及随之而来的所有单身派对闹剧。所以，是的，我没打算做私人工作。在我获得合格工作之前，我确实为组织做过一些简短的项目工作，这基本上是利用我的研究技能，试图为组织整理一份报告，我确实非常喜欢。但说实话，私人工作的想法不是我自己的，它是我的丈夫向我提出的。所以，我在成人服务机构工作时休了第二次产假，所以我离开了那个CAMHS服务机构，去了离家更近的成人服务机构。再次，我非常珍惜在那里的时光，我学到了很多，那就是我成为创伤专家的时刻。我怀念我的
colleagues I do I do I do um so and I miss my colleagues in CAMHS as well, you know, but you can keep them as friends once you leave is what I'd say. So my youngest was starting preschool at the school and I was only by that stage working three days a week. So after my first maternity leave, I went back to the CAMHS service four days a week. And then when I went back from my maternity leave for the adult service, I decided I only wanted to be three because as anybody who works four days will tell you, you're basically doing five days work in four for less pay. So I wanted to absolutely be part time. And so, yeah, it is a bit of a shock when your wages go down um but you have to kind of cut cut your cloth accordingly is what um is what my my parents
同事，我确实怀念。我也怀念我在CAMHS的同事，你知道，但正如我所说，离开后你可以和他们保持朋友关系。所以我的小儿子当时开始上学前班，那时我每周只工作三天。所以在我第一次产假后，我回到CAMHS服务机构每周工作四天。然后当我从成人服务机构的产假回来时，我决定我只想工作三天，因为正如任何工作四天的人都会告诉你的那样，你基本上是在用四天的时间做五天的工作，却拿着更少的工资。所以我绝对想做兼职。所以，是的，当你的工资下降时，这确实有点令人震惊，但你必须根据自己的情况量入为出，这是我的父母
would have told me um so I had those two days with um with my um well being a parent and doing all of the school run bits and pieces for the eldest but then when the youngest was going to be starting preschool my husband was like well what are you going to do with those three hours a week um on a Wednesday and a Thursday and I was like did I maybe have a nap maybe have a facial tidied the house and he was like you could start some private work. And I was like, oh, I could. But I didn't feel like a proper enough psychologist, I don't think. It felt like I needed to be some, I don't know, something different. Well, I didn't feel like I was it. But I was, oh, well, yeah, maybe some more money would be nice.
会告诉我的。所以我用那两天时间陪伴孩子，做所有的接送工作。但当小儿子要开始上学前班时，我丈夫问：“你每周三和周四那三个小时打算做什么？”我说：“也许睡个午觉，也许做个面部护理，打扫一下房子。”他说：“你可以开始做一些私人工作。”我说：“哦，我可以。但我感觉自己还不够像一个真正的心理学家。”我觉得我需要成为某种……我不知道，某种不同的东西。好吧，我不觉得我是。但我当时想，哦，好吧，也许能多赚点钱也不错。
You know, I don't know. So I was part of a psychologist network for private professionals, and I'd been part of it probably for a year. So I knew it was possible. And one of my good friends, Cara, I know she won't mind me mentioning her, she was already working in private and had done for quite some time. And she was like, you'd be fabulous at it just you know do it do it so um to cut a very long story short um I found myself two clinics one that had space on a Wednesday one that had space on a Thursday that were traveling distance from my children's school so that I could drop them off for 8.45 and then hot foot it by car to the clinic and then see
你知道，我不知道。所以我是一个私人专业心理学家网络的一员，我加入它可能已经一年了。所以我知道这是可能的。我的好朋友Cara，我知道她不介意我提到她，她已经在私人领域工作了很长一段时间。她说：“你会做得非常棒，只要去做就行了。”所以，长话短说，我找到了两家诊所，一家周三有空位，一家周四有空位，距离我孩子的学校都在通勤距离内，这样我就可以在8:45送他们去学校，然后开车赶到诊所，然后看
two clients and then hot foot it back to the school to pick up my youngest just in time so that was quite an action-packed three hours it really was but then the pandemic happened um so I'd started that in September 2019 and then by the time March came around obviously it all shifted online and then I didn't have the school run to worry about so I increased it to three kinds because there was increased demand because of the pandemic and then randomly ended up setting up an evening clinic one evening a week so before I knew it I was then doing eight sessions a week and I was so terrified of not getting the tax right that I saved every single penny um other than um my costs and my overheads um for you know software and you know ICO um all of the uh insurance well all of that jazz um because I didn't want to then suddenly not have enough money so it got to a position where I was like oh I'm gonna be a higher
两个客户，然后赶回学校接我的小儿子，时间刚刚好。所以那三个小时非常紧凑，确实如此。但后来大流行发生了，所以我从2019年9月开始这样做，到了3月，显然一切都转移到了线上，然后我不用担心接送孩子的问题了，所以我增加到了三个客户，因为大流行导致需求增加。然后随机地，我最终每周设置了一个晚间诊所。所以在我意识到之前，我每周做八次会话。我非常害怕税务处理不当，所以我存下了每一分钱，除了我的成本和管理费用，比如软件、ICO、保险，所有这些……因为我不想突然没有足够的钱。所以到了一个地步，我想，哦，我很快就会成为高
rate taxpayer before too long I am working working myself to the bone for actually no benefits. And so it just made me think, well, could I shift the balance slightly? Could I maybe do two days in the NHS and then have three days in private practice? And, you know, the pandemic kind of was resolving itself. The kids are back at school. And by the time I actually went all in self-employed, it was April 2021 because my request to drop down had been declined. And it was interesting that sometimes when we might get what we want, we might realize it's not what we want um and it was actually as I was doing my appeal for that that I suddenly realized if they say yes I think I might be a bit disappointed I might be a bit sad um and I think that that speaks volumes doesn't it because if you then get what you want and you still don't want it maybe that's not what you know that's not the course of action you should be taking so I did then make the decision
税率纳税人了，我为了实际上没有任何好处而拼命工作。所以这让我思考，我能稍微调整一下平衡吗？我能每周在NHS工作两天，然后在私人执业中工作三天吗？而且，大流行正在自行解决。孩子们回到了学校。当我真正全职自雇时，已经是2021年4月了，因为我要求减少工作时间的请求被拒绝了。有趣的是，有时当我们得到我们想要的，我们可能会意识到那不是我们想要的。实际上，当我在做上诉时，我突然意识到，如果他们答应了，我想我可能会有点失望，我可能会有点难过。我认为这说明了很多问题，不是吗？因为如果你得到了你想要的，但你仍然不想要它，也许那不是你应该采取的行动。所以我做出了决定，
to go all in which is you know not an easy decision someone on my cohort had always planned to be a trainee and then set up their own practice and that is what they did um right from the beginning and to watch that going on as someone that was newly qualified it was like oh gosh that feels like oh wild you know they had a website and everything um so to to kind of go through that process myself but but no I already could pay my bills if needed. You know, I got my accountant to help me calculate what I needed as a bare minimum to kind of make my ends meet and still pay my tax and my national insurance and all of that jazz. And to actually take out any passive assets at that time. So by that time, I did have the tricky brain kit and the grief
全力以赴，这（你知道）不是一个容易的决定。我那一届有人一直计划成为实习生，然后建立自己的诊所，这就是他们所做的，从一开始就是这样。作为一个刚获得资格的人，看着这一切发生，感觉就像，哦天哪，这感觉太疯狂了。他们有网站，什么都有。所以，我自己经历那个过程，但没有，如果需要的话，我已经可以支付账单了。你知道，我让我的会计师帮我计算我作为最低限度需要多少钱，以维持收支平衡，同时支付我的税款和国民保险，以及所有这些。并在当时取出任何被动资产。所以到那时，我确实有了“Tricky Brain Kit”和《Grief Collective》书以及其他一些零碎的东西，但如果我们把这些拿出来，它不像常规的一对一客户工作那样可预测。所以我们把它排除在外，并帮助我得出了我每周需要看多少客户的数字。这就是我开始的地方。
collective book and a couple of different bits and pieces but if we took that out but it's not as predictable as regular one-to-one client work so we took that off the table and kind of helped me have a figure for how many clients I needed to see a week so that's where I started um but it still feels like a big deal um and I would say that I never felt alone so people are like won't you be lonely but actually my accountant is so lovely she feels like part of my team um and I've got a virtual assistant Hannah who helps me do bits and pieces for socials and keeps me on track and thinking I haven't got any content planned I haven't got any content plan what are you going to do um and so at that time we were running regular five-day challenges for people with complex trauma and so um yeah I think Hannah and I were doing more work together at that time because there's lots involved in running a
但这仍然感觉是一件大事。而且我想说，我从来没有感到孤独。所以人们会问：“你不会感到孤独吗？”但实际上，我的会计师非常可爱，她感觉就像我团队的一部分。我还有一位虚拟助理Hannah，她帮我处理社交媒体的零碎事务，让我保持正轨，并思考“我还没有计划任何内容，我没有内容计划，你打算怎么办？”所以当时我们正在为患有复杂创伤的人举办定期的五天挑战赛。所以，是的，我想Hannah和我在那个时候一起做了更多的工作，因为举办一个挑战赛涉及很多事情。
challenge um so I never felt by myself I've never felt lonely. And of course, when you're seeing clients, you are connecting with people. And I have done some networking here and there and I'm part of various groups. But, you know, I still talk to Cara most days and other kind of psychologist friends as well. So, yeah, that's a very long answer to your question again. But that's that's what happened. I'm just gonna gonna take that um the kind of you don't feel lonely but um you also mentioned during the camp that you really missed the people you worked with in in the services as well um and i know from my from
所以我从来没有感到孤单，我从来没有感到孤独。当然，当你见到客户时，你是在与人建立联系。我确实在这里和那里做了一些社交活动，我是各种团体的一员。但是，你知道，我仍然每天和Cara交谈，还有其他心理学家朋友。所以，是的，这又是对你问题的很长的回答。但这就是发生的事情。我只是想……你提到的那种“你不感到孤独”，但你也在CAMHS期间提到你真的很怀念在服务机构一起工作的同事。而且我知道从我
my own experience i i feel like part of my um continuous development has happened in kind of what are kind of informal micro-supervisions, just these passing conversations or in my role as an AP, I was really fortunate that we always had two trainees in the team and we we had a had our own room and they would they would come in from a session and they'd be you know quite often they'd be everyone would turn their chairs around and they'd be like a little kind of debrief and sort of sharing ideas we also did a balance group as well every month with the whole team which would be six of us um so for anyone who doesn't know what a balance group is it's a basic a case discussion that's unprepared so one person presents a case generally something that they're really stuck with and that can be either with a client or working with another team or working with a system but something where they're stuck
自己的经验来看，我觉得我的一部分持续发展发生在非正式的微型督导中，只是这些随意的谈话。或者在我担任助理心理学家（AP）的角色时，我非常幸运，团队中总是有两名实习生，我们有自己的房间，他们会从会话中回来，每个人都会转过椅子，进行一个小型的汇报，分享想法。我们每个月还会和整个团队进行一次Balint小组活动，总共六个人。所以对于任何不知道什么是Balint小组的人来说，它基本上是一个未经准备的案例讨论。一个人提出一个案例，通常是他们真正卡住的东西，这可以是关于客户，或者与另一个团队合作，或者与一个系统合作，但有些东西是他们卡住的，
and the progress of the work is it's kind of become difficult um they present that for 10 minutes i've not heard of that before is it b balance b a l i n t i think it's named after a psychologist so it comes from the around the mid-century i think it was a group of psychologists who created this group in order to kind of have supervision and share ideas and develop their thinking. It's really, yeah, it's a really good learning session. I always felt, I think generally I felt kind of perceptibly developed as a clinician after each one of those sessions um but in terms of just those informal little chats that that kind of go on there's a kind of drip um drip drip effect of development through those so i'm wondering you know when you're saying you missed the services do you how do you how do you compensate by what by working as a kind of lone private clinician how do you compensate for that
工作的进展变得困难。他们提出那个案例10分钟……我以前没听说过这个，是B-A-L-I-N-T吗？我想是以一位心理学家的名字命名的，所以它起源于世纪中叶左右，我想是一群心理学家创建了这个小组，以便进行督导、分享想法和发展他们的思维。这真的是一个非常好的学习会话。我总是觉得，我认为通常在每次会话后，我都能感觉到作为临床医生的明显发展。但就那些非正式的小聊天而言，通过这些聊天，发展有一种滴水穿石的效果。所以我很好奇，当你提到你怀念那些服务机构时，你如何补偿？作为一个孤独的私人临床医生，你如何补偿这一点？
yeah good question i'm very perceptive you should notice what i'd said and then being a bit of a disparity there so um it's very tricky because in my CAMHS service, I had my own office. And if you're busy, you can shut the door, which is quite clear communication, isn't it? Whereas in my adult service, I didn't even have my own chair. So it was agile working, but in an environment where there wasn't even really room for all the clinicians that were there. But at that point, they weren't that hot on you working from home until the pandemic happened. And then obviously everything became deathly quiet. But I have always, in my qualified capacity
是的，好问题。你非常敏锐，你应该注意到我所说的，然后那里有一点差异。所以，这非常棘手，因为在我的CAMHS服务机构，我有自己的办公室。如果你很忙，你可以关上门，这是一种非常清晰的沟通，不是吗？而在我的成人服务机构，我甚至没有自己的椅子。所以那是敏捷办公，但在一个甚至没有空间容纳所有临床医生的环境中。但在那时，他们对你居家办公并不热衷，直到大流行发生。然后显然一切都变得死一般的寂静。但我一直以来，在我的合格身份
and in my assistant and aspiring capacity, been a real grafter. I will I will you know I will take on cases I will fill my caseload we used to work with a job plan model as part of CAPA and that's something that's followed me through my career and I still have now so I was recruited to the 8a post in adults to do 50% face-to-face clinical time and when i started i was sort of told by another clinician oh it's not possible because you can't get the rooms um you know you just can't see people i've only seen probably one or two people this year um because you can't get the rooms because the rooms were given out to people all across the trust, not just to the people that worked in the building, which again, I think needed reworking. So I was like, well, I've been employed to do face-to-face time. I'm going to do it.
以及在我的助理和准心理学家身份中，都是一个真正的勤奋者。我会……你知道，我会承担案例，我会填满我的案例量。我们过去在CAPA（选择与伙伴关系方法）框架下使用工作计划模型，这是跟随我职业生涯的东西，我现在仍然拥有。所以我被招募到成人服务的8a职位，进行50%的面对面临床时间。当我开始时，另一位临床医生告诉我：“哦，这不可能，因为你拿不到房间。”你知道，你就是见不到人。我今年可能只见过一两个人，因为你拿不到房间，因为房间是分配给整个信托机构的人的，不仅仅是给在楼里工作的人，我认为这再次需要重新规划。所以我当时想，好吧，我被雇佣来做面对面时间。我要去做。
So I went all over the city getting rooms. So I wasn't always there, you know. So when I saw people, it was a really nice connection time. And actually, in my first year of working there, I only was at base on a Tuesday afternoon. That's the only time that I had to connect with people so I was used to lots of my time with my colleagues being via whatsapp or text message or emails so actually working now in isolation it doesn't feel hugely different does that make sense so it it did when I went back from my second maternity leave, I have only got two kids, it did. I was careful to give myself more time with my colleagues. And I've always really loved working with aspiring psychologists. So I loved spending time with trainees. I loved spending times with assistants and I've been able to obviously weave that into my current working model so that I'm still getting that aspect of something that I really enjoyed and that I was good at as well and of course I've still got supervisors so I've got a supervisor
所以我跑遍了整个城市去拿房间。所以我并不总是在那里。所以当我见到人时，那是一段非常美好的连接时间。实际上，我在那里工作的第一年，我只有周二下午在基地。那是我唯一可以与人联系的时间。所以我习惯了与同事的大部分时间是通过WhatsApp、短信或电子邮件进行的。所以实际上现在在孤立中工作，感觉并没有太大的不同。这有意义吗？所以，当我从第二次产假回来时（我有两个孩子），确实有。我小心地给自己更多时间与同事相处。而且我一直非常喜欢与准心理学家一起工作。所以我喜欢花时间和实习生在一起。我喜欢花时间和助理在一起，我显然已经能够将其融入到我目前的工作模式中，这样我仍然能得到我真正喜欢且擅长的东西。当然，我仍然有督导，我有我的EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）工作的督导，我还有我的通用实践的督导，不是专门针对EMDR的。而且那里也有年龄的混合，所以我的通用督导是一位年纪较大的男士，我真的很喜欢他对事情的看法，以及我们有不同的个人经历和专业经验，以及他带来的东西。但……是的，所以你知道，我仍然与人保持联系。而且因为我更多地转向了……我现在会称自己为女商人，而不仅仅是心理学家。实际上，几年前这会让我感到恶心，因为我不适应那个想法。因为我现在已经进入了那些网络，我也在商业世界中建立联系。
for my EMDR work and I've got a supervisor for my generic practice not specifically linked to EMDR and there's a mixture of ages there as well so my generic supervisor is an um an advanced a man in the advancing age and I really love his just his view on things and that we do have different personal experiences and professional experiences and what he brings to that but um yeah so you know I am still in contact with people and because I've moved more into I would now call myself a businesswoman as well as a psychologist and actually a few years ago that would have made me sick in my mouth um because it I wasn't comfortable with that with that idea because I've now moved into those networks. I'm also kind of, you know, making contacts in the business world as well.
用于我的EMDR工作，我还有一位负责我常规执业的督导，他与EMDR没有直接联系，而且那里的年龄构成也很多样。我的常规督导是一位年纪较大的长者，我非常喜欢他对事物的看法，我们确实有不同的个人经历和职业经验，他带来的视角也很有价值。是的，我仍然与人们保持联系，因为我已经更多地转型为一名商人，同时也作为一名心理学家。实际上，几年前如果有人这么说，我会感到非常反感，因为我当时并不适应这个想法。但既然我已经进入了这些网络，我也在商业领域建立了一些联系。
And I'm feeling kind of, yeah, that they're my colleagues as well. So it is, you know, I do do some networking in person and I do do some networking events. And I'm just freshly back from Galway doing a keynote speech in person. But for me, I like my own company. I think I'm quite good company. I have excellent choice in activities that I always like to do. And I always say yes to. I am good company and I I'm all right with silence um and
我也觉得他们就像我的同事一样。所以，你知道，我确实会进行一些面对面的社交，也会参加一些社交活动。我刚从戈尔韦回来，在那里做了一场面对面的主题演讲。但对我来说，我喜欢独处。我觉得自己是个很好的陪伴。我总是能选到自己喜欢的活动，而且我也总是乐于参与。我是一个很好的陪伴，我也能享受安静，嗯，还有
yeah I like radio too as company so it might sound like a really washy wishy-washy answer and solo private practice working remotely will not work for everybody but for me it works really well and it helps me to be more available for my children so that they've got mummy um picking them up and dropping them off you know nine times a week so we're meeting quite early on a friday because this is the day the day i don't do it um but it just it just suits my work-life balance and it suits me and it suits my clients and it works for me, but it might not work for everybody. That's really interesting. I mean, you say wishy-washy, but you've actually made me, I was starting to think about the triangle of supervision. So for anybody who's not aware of this, it's a kind of a model for supervision on which to structure your thinking
是的，我也喜欢把广播当作陪伴，所以这听起来可能是一个非常模糊的回答，而且远程工作的私人执业并不适合所有人，但对我来说效果非常好，它让我能更多地陪伴我的孩子，这样他们就能有妈妈接送，你知道，每周九次。所以我们在周五见得很早，因为这一天我不接送他们，但这非常适合我的工作与生活平衡，适合我，也适合我的客户，它对我有效，但可能并不适合所有人。这真的很有趣。我的意思是，你说得有点模糊，但你实际上让我开始思考督导的三角模型。所以对于任何不了解这一点的人来说，这是一种督导模型，用来构建你对
around supervision and also supervision sessions and on that triangle we have normative formative and restorative and these are the three aspects that you might want to think about covering overall during your supervision normative obviously being about standardized ways of working shared shared ways of working shared shared ways of working formative being kind of skills and knowledge and then restorative being more about you as a person and how things have felt either within the case or just just generally and I think in that answer actually you managed to kind of go around all all three of those uh points
督导以及督导会议的思考，在这个三角模型中，我们有规范性、形成性和恢复性，这三个方面是你可能希望在督导过程中全面考虑的。规范性显然是关于标准化的工作方式、共享的工作方式；形成性是关于技能和知识；而恢复性则更多是关于作为个人的你，以及在案例中或总体上的感受。我觉得在刚才的回答中，你实际上成功地涵盖了这三个要点。
you know you talked about supervision and cpd but also some new skills so like business skills and keynote speaking and also like the type of person um that you are so you're you're happy being by yourself but you're also happy with the company but also yeah that it that it works for you kind of on a on a personal level um so i'm just gonna let's do another quick lap of that triangle as well um so in terms of the normative things so the standardized ways of working as a private clinician compared to working in the nhs um what what things what things do you need that are kind of standardised? So things like insurance, do you need business insurance? Do you need insurance to cover you in case something goes wrong
你知道，你谈到了督导和持续专业发展（CPD），但也谈到了一些新技能，比如商业技能和主题演讲，还有你个人的特质，比如你乐于独处，但也乐于与人交往，而且这在个人层面上对你很有效。所以，我想让我们再快速回顾一下那个三角模型。那么，就规范性而言，即作为私人临床医生与在国民医疗服务体系（NHS）工作相比，标准化的工作方式，你需要哪些标准化的东西？比如保险，你需要商业保险吗？如果出现问题，你需要保险来覆盖你对客户的责任吗？
with a client that you are responsible for? Are there, yeah, in terms of i know that you you work online but what kind of like clinic space do you need how how do you get that how much does it cost you know um all of those kind of things do you share one with other private clinicians so um yeah do you want to just do you just want to do a quick lap of the normative section of that plan sure absolutely so um it's probably also worth saying that on the morning of my first ever private clinic i was standing in my kitchen crying because i just didn't feel enough i just didn't i was i would say i was more nervous than my first day working qualified,
关于这一点，我知道你是在线工作，但你需要什么样的诊所空间？你是如何获得的？费用是多少？你知道，所有这些事情。你会和其他私人临床医生共享空间吗？所以，你想快速回顾一下那个计划中的规范性部分吗？当然，绝对可以。值得一提的是，在我第一次私人诊所开业的那天早上，我站在厨房里哭，因为我觉得自己不够好。我可以说，我比我刚获得资格开始工作的第一天还要紧张，
more nervous. I don't remember being nervous when I was starting training because I didn't have time. I'd just got back from India as well. More nervous than my first assistant job. I think it's more nervous, probably as nervous as I was on my Viva day, really. Like it was, I just felt awful.
更紧张。我不记得我刚开始培训时感到紧张，因为我没时间。我当时刚从印度回来。比我第一份助理工作时更紧张。我觉得更紧张，可能和我答辩那天一样紧张，真的。就像，我感觉糟透了。
And the idea of asking someone for money for what I did that felt like common sense, I think that's the thing. We get so schooled into what we're doing that the idea of actually being paid more than £22 an hour or whatever it was that we're on at the time, it felt like I was robbing a bank. It felt like I was doing something really, really naughty. But actually, and I felt like I needed to be able to give extra do more to earn that money because I was so institutionalized by being an employee um I would say that certainly initially the work was easier um than than the NHS work I'd been doing
而且向别人收取我所做工作的费用，这感觉像是常识，我想这就是问题所在。我们受到的训练太深了，以至于想到实际收入超过每小时22英镑，或者当时我们拿的任何工资，都感觉像是在抢银行。感觉我做了一件非常、非常淘气的事情。但实际上，我当时觉得我需要能够提供额外的东西，做更多的工作来赚取那笔钱，因为我被作为雇员的身份制度化了。我想说，最初这份工作确实比我在NHS做的工作更容易，
um and very quickly I was like oh I guess, it's fine. It's all right. So, yeah, you do need to register with the Information Commissioner's Office, the ICO. I mentioned those earlier, but I didn't give you the full details about what ICO was. And you need to have processes set up for kind of your GDPR, how you're going to keep notes, all of that jazz. Mine's all electronic. And you need to have indemnity insurance. Sorry, does that mean that you... So in the NHS, we are ardent note takers and we can be audited.
而且很快我就觉得，哦，我想，这没问题。挺好的。所以，是的，你需要向信息专员办公室（ICO）注册。我之前提到过，但我没有给你关于ICO的详细信息。你需要为你的GDPR（通用数据保护条例）建立流程，如何保存笔记，所有这些杂事。我的都是电子化的。而且你需要有赔偿保险。抱歉，那意味着你……所以在NHS，我们是热心的笔记记录者，我们可以被审计。
And in fact, patients can access their own records and their progress notes. It's information that is kind of right rightfully theirs and so I'm assuming that means that that's that's the same working privately but there's a different slightly different process in which you have to hold that data but also make it auditable is it auditable by the hcpc so yes the hcpc at any time could contact you and tell you that you've been selected for audit um the the clinical platform i use makes it all quite easy to kind of to download and share notes if if and when required and of course so clients still like they can in the nhs request access to their notes. But largely speaking, they don't tend to unless it's some legal funded work or something. But yeah, it's still absolutely the process.
事实上，患者可以访问他们自己的记录和进度笔记。这些信息理所当然是属于他们的，所以我假设在私人执业中也是一样的，只是你保存这些数据的方式略有不同，而且它必须是可审计的。它是由健康与护理专业委员会（HCPC）审计的吗？是的，HCPC随时可能联系你，告诉你已被选中进行审计。我使用的临床平台让下载和共享笔记变得非常容易，如果需要的话。当然，客户仍然像在NHS一样，可以要求访问他们的笔记。但总的来说，除非是涉及法律资助的工作或其他情况，否则他们通常不会这样做。但是的，这绝对仍然是流程。
And you do need to have indemnity insurance. But actually, I would suggest to anyone listening to this, perhaps even when working at trainee level, perhaps even before that, to consider insurance anyway. It's not a fortune. It's probably £150 a year for a level that's reasonable cover. Because I would say that the NHS will cover you, you know, in an unlimited capacity, I believe, but only if you followed the right procedures and processes. So if it's found that you haven't you're going to be liable um which i don't think they always you know they don't always tell you so if you had your own you're about to be a little bit sick thomas if you have your own cover then you're covered regardless and it just feels like a little bit of immunity um so yeah i would
而且你确实需要有赔偿保险。但实际上，我会建议听这个节目的任何人，甚至在实习阶段，甚至在那之前，都要考虑保险。这并不贵。每年大约150英镑就能获得合理的保障。因为我想说，NHS会以无限的能力覆盖你，我相信，但前提是你遵循了正确的程序和流程。所以如果发现你没有遵循，你就要承担责任，我想他们并不总是告诉你这一点。所以如果你有自己的保险，你就会感到有点安全感，所以是的，我会
say for anyone listening to this if you're working um in a clinical setting to consider getting your own um your own indemnity insurance and there's a variety of providers i use oxygen there's towergate there's there's a few others as well but i think they're all standardized pricing, you know, a bit of a price fix situation. But just something to make you feel a little bit more confident, because with the best one in the world, sometimes you may not do clinical notes within 48 hours or whatever it is that your trust wants, which then would not be you following procedures. So it might be potentially something as small as that that might lead you to standing on a stand in you
对听这个节目的任何人说，如果你在临床环境中工作，考虑购买自己的赔偿保险。有很多提供商，我用的是Oxygen，还有Towergate，还有其他一些。但我认为它们的价格都是标准化的，有点像价格固定的情况。但这只是为了让你感觉更自信一点，因为即使是最好的情况，有时你可能没有在48小时内完成临床笔记，或者你的信托机构要求的任何时间，那就不算你遵循了程序。所以这可能小到足以导致你站在法庭上，
know speaking to your honor um and all of us have been there all of us have been there where we haven't met the targets we haven't perhaps done what we should have done you know if you've maybe let your you know what's it called that training that you have to do mandatory training um if you let a bit of that lapse then technically you're not you're not compliant with trust regulations and requirements so yeah um i would look at some sort of indemnity cover um wherever you are um initially i was doing all of my private work in the clinic settings and the prices for that will absolutely vary depending on which part of the country you're in I was paying 25 pounds for um for the two hours that
你知道，对法官说话。我们所有人都经历过，我们所有人都经历过没有达到目标，或者没有做我们应该做的事情。你知道，如果你可能让你的，那个叫什么来着，必须做的强制性培训，如果你让它过期了，那么从技术上讲，你就不符合信托机构的规定和要求。所以是的，我会寻找某种赔偿保险，无论你在哪里。最初，我所有的私人工作都是在诊所环境中进行的，价格绝对会根据你所在的地区而有所不同。我当时支付25英镑，用于我需要的两个小时，
I needed so technically I could have wanged in an extra client if I'd had the space um if I'd had the time and no time limits because they tend to do it in half days so people don't often want you to do ad hoc hours here and there they will they will want to look for for something a bit bigger and more consistent but um you know that said even on harley street i've seen that you can get therapy rooms for as little as like 12 13 pounds an hour so please don't be daunted by anyone that you see talking about themselves as a harley street therapist because it's not, it doesn't mean what you think it might mean, you know. So yeah, there's quite a few steps and stages to overcome initially. But actually, it's just that all of those steps and stages have been
所以从技术上讲，如果我有空间，我有时间，我可以塞进一个额外的客户。而且没有时间限制，因为他们倾向于以半天为单位。所以人们通常不希望你在这里或那里做零星的小时，他们会想要寻找更大、更一致的东西。但话虽如此，即使在哈利街，我也见过你可以以每小时12到13英镑的价格租到治疗室。所以请不要被任何谈论自己是哈利街治疗师的人吓倒，因为这并不意味着你认为的那样。所以是的，最初有很多步骤和阶段需要克服。但实际上，如果你以前被雇佣过，所有这些步骤和阶段都已经为你做好了。
done for you if you've been employed before. And now you're responsible for it yourself. But yes, it's not it doesn't need to be as daunting as you think it might be and connecting with other professionals who've been through that can be really useful too might be worth saying I've also got a webinar a masterclass on considering going all in self-employed so if anyone's interested in checking that out they can check out the details in the show notes how about so so that's the kind of the the kind of normative way and i i'm i suppose within that actually that there seem to be some some new skills as well that are unique therefore to working privately like you know organizing these things a lot of kind of admin but also
现在你需要自己负责了。但是的，它不需要像你想象的那样令人生畏。与经历过这些的其他专业人士联系也非常有用。值得一提的是，我还举办了一个关于考虑全职自雇的在线研讨会，如果有人感兴趣，可以查看节目说明中的详细信息。那么，这就是所谓的规范性方式。我想在其中，实际上似乎也有一些新的技能，因此是私人执业所独有的，比如组织这些事情，很多行政工作，还有
learning about you know the limits of potential limits of indemnity insurance when it comes to working for a big organisation, which I, for one, didn't know. So thanks for that pro tip. I'm going to look into that. That's not to say that I don't always work within protocol. I try to, but sometimes, yeah, maybe I'm not even aware in the moment whether I am or whether I'm not. For example, if you suddenly went home sick and you just weren't well enough, you might easily forget to do your clinical notes or, you know, not do them for a week or so, you know. And that's just part of being human. But technically, you know, it might be that if something happened to that client and the team weren't aware that that we've fallen foul of the trust procedures there and they might be like well
了解当为大机构工作时，赔偿保险的潜在限制，我个人以前不知道。所以谢谢你的专业建议。我会去研究一下。这并不是说我不总是按照协议工作。我尽量，但有时，是的，也许我当时甚至没有意识到我是否在遵循。例如，如果你突然生病回家，而你身体状况不够好，你可能很容易忘记写临床笔记，或者一周左右没写。这只是作为人类的一部分。但从技术上讲，如果那个客户发生了什么事，而团队不知道我们违反了信托程序，他们可能会说，
you know we told you to do your clinical notes within 48 hours it's a small example but but one to be aware of I think for sure yeah um you touched briefly on working privately as it working for you on a personal level, but without wanting to ask about your personal life. what kind of person do you think would succeed in private practice or in blenders, maybe part-time NHS, part-time practice, or even full-time private? Is there a type of person who is maybe more geared towards succeeding in that setting? I would say no absolutely and you know it might be the question might be are you more driven by money than any other clinician that might be part of the question you know um and I guess when we look at our own stories um and our own relationship with money there can be money trauma you know so um growing up at different times there's been
你知道，我们告诉过你要在48小时内完成临床笔记。这是一个小例子，但我认为肯定需要注意。是的，你简要提到了私人执业在个人层面上对你有效，但不想问你的私生活，你认为什么样的人会在私人执业中成功，或者在混合模式中，也许是兼职NHS，兼职私人执业，甚至是全职私人执业？是否有某种类型的人更倾向于在这种环境中成功？我会说不，绝对没有。你知道，问题可能是你是否比其他临床医生更受金钱驱动，这可能是问题的一部分。你知道，当我们审视自己的故事，以及我们自己与金钱的关系时，可能会有金钱创伤。你知道，在不同的时期成长，
money in my family and no money in my family you know there's been times where my parents were having to shop in netto um and only buy tesco value food that's kind of the era that i was growing that i grew up in um where you had to go to school with you know blue and white striped crisps you know which was like the worst thing imaginable. Um, so it was like, Oh, value, value. Um, you know, and I guess the worst thing is no crisps at all, isn't it? Cause then you can't afford crisps at all. But, um, yeah, there's been times when there's been more money and less money, but my mum's always, her mantra has always been look after the pennies and the pounds look after themselves and if we were ever going out for lunch if I didn't choose egg sandwich I'd be like like I was made
我的家庭有时有钱，有时没钱。你知道，有段时间我父母不得不去Netto购物，只买Tesco的廉价食品。那是我成长的时代，你必须带着蓝白条纹的薯片去学校，那简直是你能想象到的最糟糕的事情。嗯，就像，哦，廉价，廉价。你知道，我想最糟糕的是根本没有薯片，对吧？因为那样你就根本买不起薯片了。但，是的，有钱多的时候，也有钱少的时候，但我妈妈的座右铭一直是“省下便士，英镑自然会照顾好自己”。如果我们出去吃午饭，如果我不选鸡蛋三明治，我就好像被塑造成一个百万富翁，因为鸡蛋在任何商店的任何三明治里传统上都是最便宜的，因为它太便宜了。所以是的，我一直被教导要相当节俭，赚钱是好事。
out to be a millionaire because egg is traditionally the cheapest in any sandwich in any shop because it's so cheap so yeah I was always taught to be quite frugal and that earning money is, is good. Um, so yeah, I do like earning money. I've always earned money. So even when I was 13, I was working selling magazines that were called Candice. I think they are still around. I wrote for it recently. Um, and then I, my brother broke his leg and I ended up doing his paper round. Um, and then, um, I ended up working, washing up in a hotel and then I worked for Boots. And so I was always used to working and enjoying that and feeling like I got a sense of satisfaction and had her own money as well so you know that is just the way that for me grew up as normal that you have your own bank account you can do what you want to do you might also have a joint a joint account when you're when you're married as well but um being
所以是的，我确实喜欢赚钱。我一直都在赚钱。所以即使我13岁的时候，我也在卖一种叫Candice的杂志。我想它们现在还在。我最近还为它写过文章。然后，我哥哥摔断了腿，我最终接手了他的送报工作。然后，我最终在一家酒店洗碗，然后我在Boots工作。所以我一直习惯于工作，享受那种感觉，并觉得我有一种满足感，也有自己的钱。所以你知道，这对我来说就是成长过程中正常的，你有自己的银行账户，你可以做你想做的事。当你结婚时，你可能也会有一个联名账户，但能够
able to look after myself and be independent um have my own car and so I needed to be able to earn enough to to do you know I've got a 10 year old car Thomas you know it's I'm not I'm not extravagant as a person this necklace came from a charity shop you know um I'm not extravagant but I want to be able to afford the things I want to be able to afford um and yeah you know I don't work as many hours as you might assume. So you might be like, oh, well, she's in private practice. You know, probably she sees as many clients as she did in the NHS. She's probably a high rate taxpayer.
照顾好自己并保持独立，有自己的车，所以我需要能够赚到足够的钱来做这些。你知道，我有一辆10年的车，托马斯。你知道，我不是一个奢侈的人。这条项链来自慈善商店。你知道，我不奢侈，但我想要能够负担得起我想要负担得起的东西。而且是的，你知道，我工作的时间并不像你想象的那么多。所以你可能会想，哦，好吧，她在私人执业。你知道，可能她看到的客户和她在NHS时一样多。她可能是一个高税率纳税人。
She's probably absolutely milking it, especially with everything else she's got going on. I'm not. I'm not a higher rate taxpayer as yet. I only want to see nine clients a week, three mornings a week, because otherwise I will be depleted. You know, I won't be as good for those clients. If I was seeing 20 a week, I wouldn't have enough in the tank um so I balance myself um I go to personal training twice a week which again I know is is is quite extravagant but I pay 25 pounds a session and it does so much for me um so I'd go on a Wednesday lunchtime and a Friday morning um because that helps me build exercise into my week into my work week rather than trying to tack it on. And again, I know that's a luxury not available to everybody. But yeah, do you need to be a particular type of person, you need to be able to give yourself permission to earn money,
她可能绝对是在榨取它，尤其是考虑到她正在做的其他所有事情。我不是。我还不是高税率纳税人。我每周只想见九个客户，每周三个上午，因为否则我会精疲力竭。你知道，我不会对那些客户那么好。如果我每周见20个，我的精力就不够了。所以我平衡自己。我每周去两次私人训练，这再次我知道是相当奢侈的，但我每次支付25英镑，它对我帮助很大。所以我会在周三午餐时间和周五早上去，因为这有助于我将锻炼融入到我的工作周中，而不是试图把它硬塞进去。同样，我知道这是一种并非每个人都能享受的奢侈。但是的，你需要成为特定类型的人吗？你需要能够给自己赚钱的许可，
and to do that transaction between yourself and a client, you know, and if you're working in a in a face to face setting, there might be reception that can handle that for you. If you don't want to do that, not all clinicians want to, to handle the money or do the contracting and all of that jazz. My contracting is largely done remotely. It's done via the platform, you know, so you explain your terms and conditions, but then you send them and they're all sort of sorted out that way. But you have to give yourself permission to earn money. You know, some people do set themselves up as CIC, community interest companies, if you know, if they want to do that. But I am OK with making a profit and charging for my time.
并完成你自己和客户之间的那种交易。你知道，如果你在面对面的环境中工作，可能有前台可以为你处理。如果你不想那样做，并非所有临床医生都想处理金钱或做合同和所有那些杂事。我的合同主要是在远程完成的。它是通过平台完成的，你知道，所以你解释你的条款和条件，然后你发送它们，它们就是那样解决的。但你必须给自己赚钱的许可。你知道，有些人确实把自己设立为CIC，社区利益公司，如果他们想这样做的话。但我对盈利和为我的时间收费感到满意。
And even, you know, with the As know with the aspiring psychologist podcast I do have these free resources I do have the free Q&A's but if people have the resources and have the will there's other ways of working with me as well which are not free they're great value I still think but I know some people are a bit like charging money for that but it takes me hours and hours and hours and hours and hours even to do podcast episodes you know even to edit them even to to schedule everything it costs me money to do all of this even the platform we're streaming on and the platform that the podcast is then hosted on you know it's not free um and the stuff with the membership again that's not free I pay all of my experts within that so
甚至，你知道，对于“有抱负的心理学家”播客，我确实有这些免费资源，我确实有免费的问答，但如果人们有资源并且有意愿，还有其他与我合作的方式，它们不是免费的。它们仍然非常有价值，我认为，但我知道有些人有点像，为那个收费？但这花费了我几个小时、几个小时、几个小时、几个小时、几个小时，甚至做播客剧集，你知道，甚至编辑它们，甚至安排一切。做所有这些都要花我的钱，甚至我们正在流媒体播放的平台，以及播客随后托管的平台，你知道，它不是免费的。而且会员资格的东西，那也不是免费的，我支付其中所有专家的费用，所以
I know my you know and even people saying oh you've taken the NHS training and now you're not even working for them for some people that feels like something they don't want to do or can't can't allow themselves to do um but I feel like I've been exceptional value for the nhs and i still you know in essence do some nhs work in helping support aspiring psychologists and supporting the well-being of the country when i do different bits and pieces as well so you have to be able to give yourself permission to earn money in a way that might look different than it was if you were salaried um i've not always been this out there with with the stuff that i do um that's come with time you have to what you what you very quickly learn is that people aren't necessarily going to come flooding to you knocking
我知道我的，甚至人们说，哦，你接受了NHS的培训，现在你甚至不为他们工作了。对有些人来说，这感觉像是他们不想做或不能允许自己做的事情。但我感觉我为NHS提供了卓越的价值，而且我仍然，本质上，做一些NHS的工作，帮助支持有抱负的心理学家，并在我做不同的零碎工作时支持国家的福祉。所以你必须能够以一种可能与你领薪水时看起来不同的方式给自己赚钱的许可。我并不总是这样公开我所做的事情，那是随着时间推移而来的。你很快就会学到的是，人们不一定会蜂拥而至，敲你的门，想要给你钱。你必须乐于展示自己，并讨论你所拥有的、人们可以花钱购买的东西。这是一个过渡期。你知道，甚至我妈妈在我的社交媒体上，她说，哦，你喜欢谈论你自己，不是吗？我是个女商人，你必须那样做，你知道，这是一个舒适度曲线，我会说。那会随着时间推移而到来。如果你想把更多的钱投入到不同平台的付费广告中，以获得你的，你知道，一对一客户，那是一种可能性。我不为一对一客户发愁，他们总是，你知道，相当持续地以我想要的水平提供。
on your door wanting to ask to give you money you have to be okay with putting yourself out there and discussing the things that you have that are available for people to to spend money on and that is a transition period you know um even my mum on my social she's like oh you like talking about yourself don't you I'm a businesswoman you you have to do that, you know, and that's a comfortability curve, I would say. And that will just come with time. And if you want to funnel more money into paid for advertising with different platforms to get your, you know, your one to one clients, that's a possibility. I don't struggle for one to one clients, they're're always you know fairly consistently available at at the level that I want them um so you know so I advertise on psychology today um which keeps
所以我会在今日心理学上做广告，这让事情保持涓涓细流，但我认为，我不知道，我实际上并没有问我的客户他们是从哪里听说我的。我也许应该开始问了。是的，我觉得我对你问题的回答非常啰嗦。不，不，不，一点也不。事实上，这已经涵盖了我接下来要问的很多关于在私人执业或为NHS工作之间的利弊。是的，其中之一是财务影响。表面上看，我的意思是，我相信大多数听众都看过私人心理学家的网站，看到他们的费用，
things kind of trickling in but I think I don't know I don't actually ask my clients where they hear about me from I perhaps should start to um yeah I feel like all my answers to your questions are very rambling no no no not not at all um and in fact i was that that's kind of covered a lot a lot of what i was gonna ask about next in terms of the the kind of maybe the pros and cons between working privately or working for the NHS. And yeah, one of those things is the financial implications. So on the face of it, I mean, I'm sure most listeners have had a look at private psychologists' websites and seen that their fees,
它们似乎是，取决于他们在国家的哪个位置，我将排除伦敦，你知道，每小时在80到150英镑之间。我们都知道我们在Band 7拿不到那么多钱，但当然也有成本影响。也没有养老金，这在NHS是众所周知的。像保险这样的成本，像诊所租金这样的成本。所以我假设，非常快地，这些成本和收入是否平衡，使其值得？值得一提的是，直到大约四个月前，即使我以我认为非常多样化和非常努力的方式工作，我仍然只给自己支付
and they seem to be, depending on whereabouts in the country they are, I'm going to exclude London, you know, somewhere between £80 and £150 an hour. We all know we're not getting paid that at Band 7, but of course there are cost implications as well. There's no pension either, which is renowned in the NHS. Costs like insurance, costs like clinic hire. So I suppose just very quickly, do those costs and earnings kind of balance out to make it worth worthwhile it's probably worth saying that until about four months ago even with me working what I consider in a really diverse way and really hard I was still only paying myself
我在NHS工作三天所得到的报酬。好的，所以你有时候会想，你知道，我可以，如果能每天八点到四点去服务机构，做我的工作，然后回家，那该多好。不，不再有了。我想我已经把自己置于一个无法被雇佣的位置，因为我知道我会说不。它到了一个我可能濒临无法被雇佣的位置。我对正在进行的一切以及学习如何更好地服务客户，以及如何做得更多、做得更快、减少涉及的漏洞感到非常兴奋，这是我在受雇生活中感到非常沮丧的事情。而且，你知道，只是思考，我知道学习漏斗和类似的东西，
what I got from the NHS for working three days a week okay so do you have moments where you think you know I could it would be nice just to rock up eight till four a service do my work and just and then just go home no not anymore I think I'd got myself to a position where I was unemployable um because I know I would say no um it got to a position where I was probably probably verging on being unemployable I was so energized for everything that I had going on and learning about um how to serve clients better and how to to do it more to do it quicker with less of the loopholes that were involved which was the things I found really frustrating about um employed life um and um you know just thinking about I know learning about funnels and things like that um for kind of how to get clients on board for,
关于如何让客户加入，为，你知道，与我合作之类的。我当时正在私人执业，当时有一个叫Clubhouse的平台。我想它现在还在，但它不像以前那么多了。它推出的时间让它变得疯狂。所以它推出的时间正好是在大流行期间，每个人都在家，每个人都被困住了。人们真的非常乐于能够收听这种商业专家的直播，基本上。我只是全盘接受了。我对此感到非常、非常兴奋。所以它到了这样一个位置，当我在工作时，我想在我的社交媒体上工作，或者做X、Y和Z，或者写一本书，或者你知道，所以它，当然我不是，那将是非常不公平的，但它到了这样一个阶段，
you know, working with me and stuff. I was just, I was going private at the point where there was a platform called Clubhouse. I think it is still around, but it's not around as much. And it was launched at a time that allowed it to just go wild. So it was launched at a time just in the pandemic when everyone was home, everyone was stuck. People were just really receptive to be able to listen to this kind of live streaming of business experts, basically. And I just lapped all that up. I was really, really energized by that. So it got to the position where when I was at work I wanted to be working on my socials or doing x y and z or writing a book or you know and so it and I wasn't of course I wasn't that would be really unfair but it got to the stage where
我觉得我好像在搞婚外情，你知道，我宁愿在别的地方。所以这真的帮助我做出了决定。我只是觉得现在我已经习惯了在我想做的时候做我想做的事，我会发现受雇的生活相当受限制。所以我们谈了很多关于从心理学家的角度进行私人执业，以及进入它的旅程，以及各种利弊，各种不同的工作方式和你需要考虑的事情，也许你需要成为和体现的事情。但我真的想给客户一点时间和空间，也想问问你对私人部门能独特地为客户提供什么的看法。因为我意识到，在NHS与私人之间，这可能会变成一种“我们对他们”的局面，但它们的存在都是有原因的。
I felt like I was having an affair you know that I would rather be somewhere else. And so that really helped to make my decision. And I just think now I'm so used to doing what I want to do when I want to do it, I would find employed life quite constraining. So we've talked a lot about working privately from the perspective of the psychologist and how the journey goes into it and the kind of various pros and cons, the various different ways of working and things that you need to consider and maybe the things you need to be and embody. But I really want to give a bit of time and a bit of space to the clients as well um and kind of ask you about your thoughts on what the private sector can uniquely offer clients what what does because i'm i'm aware that they could become a kind of us versus them in terms of NHS versus private, but they both exist for a reason.
它们确实都提供了对方无法提供的独特东西，或者无法完成的工作方式。所以，是的，你认为私人部门通常能为心理学独特地提供给客户什么，为什么？是的，是的，好的问题。所以我会说主要的，甚至可能是唯一的福利之一是可能没有等待。我知道，我们昨天在记录NHS等待时间时互相交谈，身体健康的等待时间被宣布长达两年，这在心理健康服务中也不罕见。所以，你知道，目前通常如果有人给我发电子邮件，他们通常至少可以进行初步评估，如果不是每周的定期时段，但肯定每两周一次，如果他们想要的话，可以在几周内变成每周一次。这在目前的NHS服务中通常是闻所未闻的，我希望它是。这是我绝对试图解决的问题，所以当我休第二次产假时，我将服务的等待时间从两年半缩短到了六个月，因为我的工作方式，因为我提供的50%的面对面服务。不幸的是，当我回到服务机构时，它又上升了。我们再也没有完全恢复过来，也许是因为我每周工作三天而不是四天。但对我来说，这是一个优势。但就NHS中可用的专业水平以及热情、关怀和承诺而言，我会说那是首屈一指的。你知道，我在NHS共事的人在整体上非常关心他们共事的客户。我想因为我当时在做
And they do both offer perhaps unique things that the other way can't offer, or ways of working that can't be done um so yeah what do you what do you think the private sector generally for for psychology can can uniquely offer clients and why yeah yeah okay good question so i would say the primary and possibly even one of the only benefits um is there might be zero weights and i know that um we speak to each other as of yesterday when record nhs weights certainly for physical health were announced as up to two years um and that's not uncommon in mental health services as well so um you know currently usually if someone emails me they can usually be seen at least for an initial assessment, if not necessarily a regular weekly slot, but certainly fortnightly to go
我最近工作的服务机构中的大部分评估，我脑子里装着客户的故事，他们不仅仅是名字，他们是人。这很困难，因为不得不对那些我永远见不到的人说再见，你知道，在我的脑海里，我评估了他们，他们永远不会排到等待名单的最前面。而通常当我见到人们时，他们会说，哦，我希望我能和你一起工作。而且通常他们确实做到了，因为我见了很多很多人。所以放弃那个服务，放弃那些客户，但是，你知道，放弃那些客户，但是，你知道，让那些非常专业的、成熟的临床医生离开我的日常雷达，而且，是的，就像你共事的跨专业工作，你知道，那是独特的，不是吗？你知道，甚至
weekly if they want to within a couple of weeks. And that's often just not heard of in NHS services currently, I wish it was. And that was something that I was absolutely trying to sort out so when I was um going on my second maternity leave I got the weights from the service down from two and a half years to six months because of the way I was working because of that face-to-face that I was offering 50 percent um and unfortunately by the time I got back to the service it had had gone up again. And we never quite recovered from that, perhaps because I was working three days a week rather than four. But that for me is an advantage. But in terms of the level of expertise available in the NHS and the level of passion and care and commitment, I would say that is second to none you know people in the NHS that I work with care so deeply about the clients they work with on on the whole um I think because I was doing
你在受雇身份下能够进行的非正式对话，如果客户在外部想要那个，就会有成本。但通常人们有诊所，甚至私人诊所也有多学科方法。但我有可以非正式合作的人，在这里和那里零星地合作。但就完整的MDT会议和案例讨论等而言，客户不一定会得到那个。但通常我们共事的客户无论如何都不需要那个。除了等待时间之外，另一个关键好处是会议次数。所以有时我正在和一个客户工作，我实际上会告诉他们，如果我们是在NHS工作，你将不符合这项服务的标准。
the majority of the assessments in the service I was most recently working at I was holding the client stories in my head they weren weren't just names, they were people. And that was difficult because having to say goodbye to people I'd never get to meet, you know, in my head, I'd assess them and they were never going to come to the top of the waiting list. Whereas often when I'd meet people, they'd be like, oh, I hope I get to work with you. And often they did because I saw lots and lots of people. So letting that service go and letting those clients go, but, you know, letting those clients go but um you know letting those really professional established clinicians out of my day-to-day radar and um yeah like the cross-professional working that you work with you know that's that's unique isn't it you know even
这是一种较低级别的干预，但他们想要从专家那里得到它，而不是从一个实际上可能以更初级的能力做一些工作的人那里得到。他们想知道他们只要需要，就能得到它。如果他们愿意，他们可以在一个月内回来。他们想要，他们可以在六个月内回来检查。你明白我的意思吗？所以他们有更多的自由。他们只要需要，就能得到它，如果他们愿意，他们可以在一个月内回来，他们想要，他们可以在六个月内回来检查。你明白我的意思吗？所以他们有更多的自由，他们有更多的控制权。但私人工作并不总是自费的。私人工作可能是法律资助的。我最喜欢共事的一些客户实际上是那些被他们自己的职业健康保险计划覆盖的人，这实际上感觉更像NHS类型的工作。所以即使这些合同利润较低，我也确实喜欢为他们工作，你知道，为
the informal conversations you're able to have in an employee capacity that then have a cost attached for the client if they want that outside of that but often people have got practices that have got even private practices have got multi kind of discipline approaches but I've got people that I can work with informally and kind of ad hoc here and there but in terms of the full MDT meeting and the case discussion and stuff, clients aren't necessarily going to get that. But often the type of clients we're working with don't need that anyway. And one of the other key benefits other than waiting times is session number. So sometimes I'm working with a client and I will actually say to them, if we were working in the NHS, you wouldn't meet the criteria for this service.
我从那里挑选的客户类型。是的，这在MDT工作方面真的很有趣，你仍然可以访问那个。是的，鉴于你说你的客户中没有多少人需要那个，但我认为知道这一点很有用，因为这是我脑海中在诊所与多个不同团队在一起的形象，到去在花园棚里工作，它确实看起来好像你突然真的独自一人了。所以很高兴知道那仍然是可以转移的。你认为什么，所以，好吧，只是为了谈谈你与不太复杂的客户工作的那一点。所以我知道在NHS
And it's a lower level of intervention, but they want it from a specialist rather than someone that could actually probably do some of the work in a more junior capacity. And they want to know that they've got that for as long as they need to. And if they want to, they can dip back in a month. They want to, they can check back in in six months. Do you see what I mean? So they've got more freedom. They've got that for as long as they need to and that if they want to they can dip back in a month they want to they can check back in in six months do you see what I mean so they've got more freedom they've got more control but private work is not always self-funded private work might be legal funded it might be some of my favorite clients to work with are actually those that are covered by their own occupational health cover plans and that feels a bit more like NHS type working actually so even though those contracts are less lucrative I do enjoy the work for them you know for the
服务中，有时你共事的客户有时真的需要在一个住院环境中，因为他们真的不健康，他们没有茁壮成长。而我不会在私人执业中必然与处于那种危机水平的客户工作，那会感觉不安全，那对我对客户来说都会感觉有风险。所以我认为我是在与复杂但不是，不是处于积极危机中的客户工作，如果这有意义的话。是的，绝对。而且听起来你说的关于会议数量的方式，是的，我知道在NHS，通常有一种委托去做一定数量的会议，特别是在像CBT这样的事情上。而且那当然是，它是一种基于证据的，嗯，会议限制，你知道，嗯，我认为在六次会议内
type of clients that I pick up from there. Yeah that's really interesting in terms of the MDT working, that you can still access that. Yeah, given that you say not many of your clients require that, but it's useful to know, I think, because that's one of my, one of the images of my mind of being in a clinic with multiple different teams to going to working you know in a garden shed it's it does it does seem like there's suddenly you're really on your own and so it's good to know that um that can still be transferable what do you think so well just to speak to that to the point where you're working with less complex clients so what I know in NHS
你得到你最大的效果，然后它就趋于平稳了。所以我假设在委托和资源方面，如果证据表明12次或更多的会议，你只是趋于平稳，那么你不应该真的委托超过12次会议。但它确实做到的，我假设，在私人环境中是给客户控制他们想要多少的权力。显然，尽管这是一个协作对话，
services is often you're working with clients sometimes who really need to be in an inpatient setting because they're really not well they're not thriving whereas I wouldn't necessarily work with clients at that level of crisis in private practice that would feel unsafe that would feel risky for me and for the client so I think I'm working with complex but not um not actively in crisis clients if that makes sense yeah absolutely and it and it sounds also the way you're saying about the kind of the amount of sessions and yeah I'm aware in the NHS um there's generally a kind of commission to do a certain amount of sessions especially when it comes to things like cbt um and that of course is it's kind of evidence-based um uh limit on sessions that you know um i think it's within six sessions
关于他们是否也需要它。但这肯定看起来有一点更多的控制和关于它的讨论，这很好。我也想知道人口群体，他们可能不会访问NHS的主流服务。不是他们不能，而是他们不会。我特别感兴趣的事情之一是精英足球。我们没有时间深入探讨那个，但有很多临床表现正在发生，
you get your most effects and then it kind of plateaus. So I suppose in terms of commissioning and resource, if the evidence says that 12 or more sessions, you just plateau, then you shouldn't really be commissioning more than 12 sessions. But what it does do, I suppose, in the private setting is give clients the control over how much they want. Obviously, notwithstanding the fact that that is a collaborative conversation
在精英足球中也有一些临床问题，但你不会必然看到一个英格兰足球运动员坐在NHS的候诊室里。所以，你知道，生活和工作在一个非常结构化的世界里的人，比如精英足球或军队，可能不会找到通往NHS主流服务的道路。所以可能存在潜在的人口群体，私人部门可以独特地与他们工作。但我想要问的一件事是，基于证据的实践与创新。所以，嗯，总的来说，在私人部门，嗯，其成功的一个论点是它有点不太受监管，所以它更
about whether they need it as well. But it certainly seems a bit more kind of control and discussion around that, which is good. I also wonder about population groups as well, who might not access mainstream services in the NHS. Not that they can't, but that they wouldn't. One of the things that I'm particularly interested in is elite football. We don't have time to go into that, but there are many clinical presentations going on
开放，能够创新和尝试新的东西，这些东西可能没有经过测试或证明，或者没有巨大的或几十年的证据基础。我有时在LinkedIn上看到人们发布关于他们正在做的事情，他们正在使用的模型，我从来没听说过它，我查了一下，证据基础很薄弱或完全不存在。我非常认真地对待作为科学家实践者的模型，到目前为止，我可能会改变主意，但我把它作为一种义务，我认为如果我不是一个科学家实践者，我就不是一个临床心理学家。但在那的另一面，是否有机会尝试一些东西，虽然没有被证明，但可能有一些证据，而虽然它可能不会因为那个原因被NHS委托，但那里有一个机会。
and some clinical issues in elite football, but you wouldn't necessarily see an england footballer sat in an nhs waiting room um so i you know people who live who live and work in a world which is very structured like elite football or like the military might not find their way to an nhs mainstream service so there's perhaps potential population groups who um with whom the the private sector can can uniquely work um but one of the things that I wanted to ask about um is evidence-based practice versus innovation so um generally speaking in the private sector um one of the the arguments for its success is that it's kind of less regulated so it's more
以及精英足球中的一些临床问题，但你未必会看到一名英格兰足球运动员坐在国民医疗服务体系（NHS）的候诊室里。所以，那些生活和工作在高度结构化环境中的人，比如精英足球界或军队，可能不会去寻求NHS的主流服务。因此，私营部门或许有潜力与某些特定群体进行独特的合作。但我想要问的一点是，循证实践与创新之间的关系。总的来说，在私营部门，其成功的一个论点是它受到的监管较少，因此它更
open to be able to innovate and to try new things that are maybe not tested or proven or have a huge or decades-long evidence base and I sometimes see that with people on LinkedIn who might post about something they're doing a model that they're using, I've never heard of it, I look it up, the evidence base is slim or completely absent. And I take very seriously the model of being a scientist practitioner and so far I might change my mind, but I take that as an obligation and I think if I'm not being a scientist practitioner I'm not being a clinical psychologist but on the flip side of that is there an opportunity to try something which although hasn't been proven might have some evidence but whereas it might not be commissioned by the NHS for that reason, there's an opportunity there
开放，能够进行创新并尝试一些未经测试或验证，或者没有长达数十年证据基础的新事物。我有时会在LinkedIn上看到人们发布他们正在使用某种我从未听说过的模型，我去查了一下，发现其证据基础非常薄弱甚至完全缺失。我非常认真地对待“科学家-实践者”这一模式，目前我可能会改变主意，但我将其视为一种义务。我认为如果我不遵循“科学家-实践者”的原则，我就不是一名临床心理学家。但另一方面，是否存在一种机会去尝试一些虽然尚未被完全证明，但可能具备一定证据的事物？尽管它们可能因为这个原因不会被NHS采纳，但在私营领域却存在这样的机会。
in the private sector to innovate and use new models and new ideas. What do you think about that? Yeah, I think there probably is. It's not really something that I have done. I'd say I'm still a very similar clinician now than I was when I was employed but you know there are people for example someone had on the podcast recently who were doing sort of eco-therapy and stuff outside the therapy room and that's a really nice opportunity to bring something of yourself but also stuff that's that's got an emerging evidence base but I think it gives you freedom and permission to to be yourself and to niche as well. So you only have to work with the clients and the populations that you want to.
在私营部门进行创新并使用新的模式和理念。你对此怎么看？是的，我想可能确实有。这并不是我真正做过的事情。我想说，我现在作为临床医生，与我受雇时相比，并没有太大区别。但你知道，有些人，比如我最近在播客上采访过的人，他们正在进行某种生态疗法，在治疗室之外做一些事情，这是一个非常好的机会，可以展现自我，而且这些方法也有了初步的证据基础。但我认为这给了你自由和许可去展现真实的自己，也可以专注于特定的领域。所以你只需要与你想要合作的客户和群体一起工作。
So I only work with over 17s, really over 18s, ideally. For me, working online only doesn't feel safe enough for working with children and young people. So I'm now not working with any children's or family services, which feels different because I did really love that years ago. But I now feel that I am, I do feel equally as competent in working with children and adults because of the length of time I've done both. but I would say I'm now a specialist adult clinician um and uh I kind of will see trauma complex trauma complex grief um and that's you know I will do OCD because it's usually linked with complex trauma but I wouldn't necessarily see myself as a as a specialist OCD clinician but if there's complex trauma roots then that often is something that I will do but I can say no to you know other bits and pieces that I don't think I'm
所以我只与17岁以上，最好是18岁以上的人合作。对我来说，仅在线工作对于处理儿童和青少年问题来说不够安全。所以我现在不从事任何儿童或家庭服务，这感觉很不同，因为几年前我真的很喜欢那样做。但我现在觉得，由于我从事这两项工作的时间很长，我在处理儿童和成人问题上同样胜任。但我会说我现在是一名成人临床专家，我会处理创伤、复杂性创伤、复杂性哀伤，你知道，我也会处理强迫症，因为它通常与复杂性创伤有关，但我并不一定认为自己是一名强迫症临床专家。但如果有复杂性创伤的根源，那通常是我会做的事情，但我可以拒绝其他我不认为自己是
the best clinician for you know whereas when you're in a team you can't always do that yeah absolutely um I think from my from my limited time already I can see that there are particular um particular types of work that I I would prefer not to do if I if I could choose and that I'd rather put my energy into things that I guess the path of least resistance here's here's a here's a type of client a type of issue a type of way of working that just feels really good to me so um yeah that's that's um yeah it's like I could do that but it will take me a lot more and I will need to do lots of reading around that to do that. Or I could do what I'm already in my zone of genius in, as they say in business terms,
最适合的临床医生，你知道，而在团队中你并不总能做到这一点。是的，绝对。我想从我有限的时间里，我已经可以看出，有些特定类型的工作，如果可以选择的话，我宁愿不做，我宁愿把精力投入到那些我认为阻力最小的事情上。这里有一种客户、一种问题、一种工作方式，让我感觉非常好。所以，是的，这就像我可以做那个，但这会花费我更多精力，我需要做大量的阅读才能完成。或者我可以做我已经在我的天才领域内的事情，正如商业术语中所说的那样，
where actually things will come more freely to me and I will be more help to you as a clinician because I'm having to do less learning and scrabbling and kind of getting to where you need me to be you know when I when you're working with me in complex trauma you want me to say oh actually this is a really good example of that and I wonder if this is happening not me going all right how do we how do we work with pain again like what's that approach what's that thing oh I don't know what I'm doing there like you know I wouldn't ever say to a client I don't think I'm the best choice for you this has turned out a bit different than we expected and they might still say I still want to work with you because I like you best and it's
实际上事情会更自然地来到我身边，作为临床医生，我会对你更有帮助，因为我需要做的学习和摸索更少，不需要费力去达到你需要我达到的水平。你知道，当你和我一起处理复杂性创伤时，你希望我说，哦，实际上这是一个很好的例子，我想知道这是否正在发生，而不是让我去想，好吧，我们怎么再次处理疼痛？那种方法是什么？那是什么东西？哦，我不知道我在那里做什么。你知道，我永远不会对客户说，我不认为我是你的最佳选择，这结果有点出乎意料，他们可能仍然会说，我仍然想和你一起工作，因为我最喜欢你，而且这
like well you can make that informed choice but I still I'm still regularly telling you you know this is largely pain work I'm not much good at pain work. And they're still making that choice to work with me. That's their choice, you know, but I wouldn't generally go ahead picking up pain clients because I know I'm rubbish with pain. Personally, you know, I don't necessarily mean rubbish clinically, but really difficult. And that said, if anyone's watching Painkiller on Netflix at the moment, I've just finished it yesterday with my husband. It's really, really interesting. And yeah, useful watch as an aspiring or qualified psychologist.
就像，好吧，你可以做出那个知情的选择，但我仍然会定期告诉你，你知道，这主要是疼痛治疗，我不擅长疼痛治疗。他们仍然做出选择与我一起工作。那是他们的选择，你知道，但我通常不会去接疼痛客户，因为我知道我不擅长处理疼痛。就个人而言，你知道，我不一定是指临床上很差，但真的很困难。话虽如此，如果有人现在正在看Netflix上的《止痛药》，我昨天刚和丈夫看完。它真的非常非常有趣。而且，作为一名有抱负或合格的心理学家，这是一个有用的观看内容。
Thanks. I'm just aware of the time that it's maybe slightly longer chat than you usually have. So I think maybe we should think about sort of moving to the end. So I'm just going to ask you a kind of general, your general thoughts and views around the future. Maybe a general reflection, if you want to, on the future of clinical psychology in the private sector and the NHS. If you want to on the future of clinical psychology in the private sector and the nhs um if you want to get politicized about that you can um but maybe
谢谢。我只是意识到时间可能比你通常的聊天时间稍微长了一点。所以我认为也许我们应该考虑结束了。所以我只是要问你一个关于未来的普遍想法和观点。如果你愿意的话，也许可以对临床心理学在私营部门和NHS的未来做一个普遍的反思。如果你愿意的话，可以对临床心理学在私营部门和NHS的未来发表一些政治性的看法，但也许
more specifically um the future of you yourself and and it can be a long career um and yeah um just yeah tell us about what what what you what you see in the future for both of those things. Yeah, I mean, I can't ever really imagine not doing psychology. So I can't imagine retiring and not being a psychologist. And I know that's not unusual as as as a profession um because I feel like it's part of my identity you know I love being a psychologist um I love being Dr Marianne Trent actually it feels weird that I just wouldn't do that that I wouldn't and I wouldn't continue to earn money in in some capacity because the state
更具体地说，关于你自己的未来，这可以是一个漫长的职业生涯，是的，告诉我们你对这两者的未来有什么看法。是的，我的意思是，我真的无法想象不做心理学。所以我无法想象退休后不再是一名心理学家。我知道这作为一种职业并不罕见，因为我觉得它是我的身份的一部分。你知道，我热爱成为一名心理学家，我热爱成为Marianne Trent博士。实际上，如果我不这样做，如果我不继续以某种身份赚钱，那会感觉很奇怪，因为国家
pension's not going to be enough and I left the NHS too early to have a really well and I'm the wrong age to have a really nice NHS pension and I have got a private pension but I probably started that too late like so I think many of us are going to need some sort of supplementary income. I don't own any properties to rent out or anything. You know, that's not something we've gone down the route of. But it's interesting because what quickly became apparent when I first qualified is that the NHS training scheme is not a guarantee of employment. And ordinarily, there's jobs available. But what we learned in 2011 is there's no guarantee of any NHS employment. It doesn't lead to, you know, a band seven or preceptorship role. There's not funding earmarked for paid, qualified work, just because you've been trained as a qualified
养老金是不够的，我离开NHS太早了，没有一个非常好的，而且我的年龄也不对，无法获得非常好的NHS养老金。我有一个私人养老金，但我可能开始得太晚了。所以我认为我们许多人将需要某种补充收入。我没有任何房产可以出租之类的。你知道，那不是我们选择的道路。但有趣的是，当我刚获得资格时，很快就显而易见，NHS培训计划并不能保证就业。通常情况下，有工作机会。但我们在2011年学到的是，没有任何NHS就业的保证。它不会导致，你知道，七级或实习角色。没有为有偿、合格的工作预留资金，仅仅因为你被培训为一名合格的
psychologist and so I could potentially have moved into private work at that point but really I feel what is useful about band seven's roles is that you are able to to come up to full speed of being qualified which really full speed is 8a I would say that's traditionally how they were thought about you know two years of band seven and then preceptorship to 8a and certainly in my experience that's absolutely the case I've become a better and better clinician the longer and longer I've been qualified but in terms of the future of clinical psychology it's really tricky I think some element of AI will come in and that will be sad for the profession and sad for the clients as well because connection with another human and being able to share things that you feel are deeply personal and private with someone where it feels safe and trusted to do that.
心理学家，所以我当时可能已经转向了私人工作，但实际上我觉得七级角色的有用之处在于，你能够达到完全合格的速度，我认为完全速度是8a，我认为传统上他们是这样考虑的，你知道，两年的七级，然后是到8a的实习期。当然，根据我的经验，绝对是这样。我担任临床医生的时间越长，我就变得越好。但就临床心理学的未来而言，这真的很棘手。我认为人工智能的某些元素会介入，这对这个职业来说是可悲的，对客户来说也是可悲的，因为与另一个人建立联系，并能够与一个让你感到安全和信任的人分享你认为非常个人和私密的事情。
Honestly, it's just the biggest privilege. I don't know, you know, if the funded NHS route will continue in this regard for for the foreseeable you know if we think about will this still be like this in 10 years how is it possible that counseling psychologists who largely are similarly qualified and experienced to ourselves are having to self-fund you know and forensics as well like how is that okay how has that been that there's only funding for educational and, and, and clinical that's feels massively unjust. So will it be that it will be leveled across the board? Or will it be that it will become self funding, you know, you're starting to see more courses, signing up to self funding routes over the last couple of years um I don't
老实说，这简直是最大的荣幸。我不知道，你知道，如果资助的NHS路线在可预见的未来会继续这样，如果我们考虑10年后还会是这样吗？咨询心理学家在很大程度上与我们具有相似的资格和经验，却不得不自费，这怎么可能？法医也是如此，这怎么可以？怎么会只有教育和临床有资助？这感觉非常不公正。所以，这会是全面平等的吗？还是会变成自费？你知道，在过去几年里，你开始看到更多的课程签署自费路线。我不知道
know um I still feel like I've got the best job in the world you know that it allows me to do clinical work it allows me to do um you know I've got tv series starting on Sunday it allows me to write for the media it in the Galway it allows me to stand on stage in Galway and talk to people who are equally passionate about mental health and the career of psychology and that is all because I did a psychology undergraduate degree you know that's what my um you know my key stakeholder benefit was to begin with that's allowed me to jump through all the hoops to get where I am to be sitting with you discussing my private career. Why would you not want to do this job? But, you know, will it always exist like this? I don't know, is the answer. Yeah, I suppose a big, yeah, those are big elements, aren't they?
我仍然觉得我拥有世界上最好的工作，你知道，它允许我做临床工作，它允许我做，你知道，我周日有电视连续剧开播，它允许我为媒体写作，它允许我站在Galway的舞台上，与同样对心理健康和心理学职业充满热情的人交谈，这一切都是因为我获得了心理学本科学位。你知道，这就是我的关键利益相关者利益，起初这让我能够跳过所有的障碍，达到我现在的地步，和你坐在一起讨论我的私人职业生涯。你为什么不想做这份工作？但是，你知道，它会永远这样存在吗？答案是我不知道。是的，我想这是一个很大的，是的，这些都是很大的要素，不是吗？
The future of the NHS, which could go in one of two extreme directions, has kind of ebbed and flowed the whole time that it's existed and continues to ebb and flow. And yeah, AI is coming over the hill real quick. But yeah, I'm also interested by the AI idea as well. Wait to see what impact that has. And yeah, actually really have no idea. I guess that's probably about as much as we should talk about. We've covered your journey out of Declan into NHS, out of NHS into a kind of blended situation, then into full-time.
NHS的未来，可能会走向两个极端方向之一，在它存在的整个过程中一直在起伏，并且继续起伏。是的，人工智能很快就会到来。但我也对人工智能的想法很感兴趣。等着看它会有什么影响。是的，实际上真的不知道。我想这大概就是我们应该谈论的全部了。我们已经涵盖了你从Declan进入NHS，从NHS进入一种混合情况，然后进入全职的旅程。
Covered some pros and cons normative formative restorative some big reflections as well in there so I think we've we've done just about um covered just about everything that that we could um so that's been really interesting I found it really interesting so hopefully uh everyone listening has found it really interesting as well. So thanks for tuning in and listening and thank you for having me as the kind of informal host for the day. It's been, yeah, it's been really fun. Also as a final note, we should mention that Marianne has her free compassionate Q&A that you can access information about across all of her socials, which is Dr. Marianne Trent.
涵盖了一些优点和缺点，规范性的、形成性的、恢复性的，还有一些大的反思，所以我认为我们已经涵盖了我们能涵盖的一切，所以这非常有趣，我发现它非常有趣，所以希望每个听众也觉得它非常有趣。所以感谢收听，感谢你让我担任今天非正式的主持人。这真的很有趣。另外，作为最后的说明，我们应该提到Marianne有她的免费同情问答，你可以在她所有的社交媒体上获取相关信息，即Dr. Marianne Trent。
And there are two sessions coming up. So the first one is Tuesday, the 3rd of October at 6 p.m. And the second one is Tuesday, the 7th of November, also at 6 p.m. So check out Marianne's socials if you are interested in joining any of those. Which I think wraps everything up for today doesn't it? So I should thank my guest Dr Marianne Trent who is also obviously the leader of this podcast um and thank you listeners for tuning in and uh yeah having a little listen to this kind of little reversal and uh and finding out uh a bit more about um marianne's journey herself at this point so thanks marianne how was it thank you so much
接下来有两场会议。第一场是10月3日星期二下午6点。第二场是11月7日星期二下午6点。所以如果你有兴趣参加其中的任何一场，请查看Marianne的社交媒体。我想这总结了今天的一切，不是吗？所以我应该感谢我的嘉宾Marianne Trent博士，她显然也是这个播客的领导者，感谢听众收听，是的，听了这个小小的反转，并更多地了解了Marianne自己的旅程，所以谢谢Marianne，感觉如何？非常感谢你
for your bravery in in in tackling me and suggesting this podcast. If anyone else has got any ideas for podcast episodes, please do feel free to let me know. Or if anyone wants Thomas to grill me on anything else, let me know and I'm sure we can sort that out as well. But you are about to start your journey as a trainee. In fact, by the time this comes out, you will be in your teaching block. So I hope it goes so well for you. Thank you again for your time, Thomas,
你的勇敢，敢于挑战我并建议这个播客。如果还有人对播客剧集有任何想法，请随时告诉我。或者如果有人想让Thomas就其他任何事情盘问我，请告诉我，我相信我们也能解决这个问题。但你即将开始作为实习生的旅程。事实上，当这个节目播出时，你将处于教学阶段。所以我希望这对你来说非常顺利。再次感谢你的时间，Thomas，
and thank you to our listeners for listening. and let this be your guide with this podcast that you'll side to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming
也感谢我们的听众收听。让这个播客成为你的指南，让你在成为合格心理学家的道路上前进。这是与Marianne Trent博士一起的《有抱负的心理学家》。我叫Jana，我是一名实习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣，我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有完美的途径可以成为一名心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力，所以如果你对成为
a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的，但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。